ils ont fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu
pendant des jours les pompiers ont
abattu des arbres creuser des tranchées
et surtout allumé des feux préventifs
près de la municipalité de high level
leur objectif créer une zone tampon de
protection entre l'immense brasier et la
ville
ces feux contrôlés qu'on allume et qu'on
éteint ensuite explique cette pompe hier
nous permettent de brûler ce qui se
trouve au sol et qui pourrait servir de
carburant pour les flammes
une fois que nous on a brûlé elle ne
peut pas s'enflammer une seconde fois la
zone brûlée peut donc servir de rempart
contre le feu car la r&d lutte contre l'
incendie de 13 à 14 heures par jour
pompière depuis sept ans
c'est la première fois qu'elle combat un
feu si près de chez elle je suis
nerveuse explique-t-elle parce que c'est
tellement un gros feu il est très proche
oui on est inquiets explique le
commandant mais on est tout de même
confiant on a fait tout ce qu'on a pu
pour se préparer contre le vent
la préparation a toutefois des limites
surtout dans la forêt boréale explique
cet élu local ancien pompier il a été
sur les lignes de front à fort mcmurray
en 2016
quand feu atteint une telle chaleur il
génère sa propre énergie on en a déjà vu
un traverser cette rivière dit il il
ajoute que chaque année des sections de
la forêt boréale brûle ça fait partie de
son sigle de régénérescence normal alors
pourquoi continuer à habiter dans une
région si exposé oui il ya un danger
dit-il mais regarder le paysage autour
de nous c'est tellement beau tellement
apaisant comme beaucoup de ses
concitoyens il n'envisage pas de partir
même si le feu menace sa communauté ici
laurence martin radio-canada élèves en
alberta